before i go to a new place i tried to do
some thorough research about it what do
i want to do there what's the weather
forecast what's the chance that it might
erupt
i learned this the hard way recently
while preparing for a trip to mount
rainier national park i somehow miss
that the mountain itself is actually a
volcano though it hasn't erupted in over
a century it has the potential to do so
again something that it would have been
nice to know more than a week before i
left for my vacation volcanoes are one
of the most dramatic examples of a
natural hazard
a naturally occurring phenomenon that
can pose risks to humans and society
natural hazards can be very dangerous
for our communities but scientists can
help people better understand the risks
that may occur where they live so
everyone can work together to prepare
safety guidelines
different places experience different
natural hazards due to local geographic
or atmospheric conditions
for example a storm on open plains could
spawn a tornado similarly a storm over
the ocean could grow into a hurricane or
a cyclone by the time it reaches the
coast these coastal rainstorms along
with their colder counterparts blizzards
are the main natural hazards that i may
run into where i live in the
mid-atlantic too much rain or snow can
be dangerous of course but scientists
have gotten pretty good at predicting
weather conditions
meteorologists use all kinds of
technologies to map where and when a
storm may form orbiting satellites can
take pictures of cloud patterns from
above
weather stations back on the surface can
use electromagnetic wave fields measured
through doppler radar to determine how
heavy rain is falling or how strongly
wind is blowing in those same clouds
they feed all of this and other data
into computer models that can help them
predict if the storm is severe enough to
become a natural hazard
for example this map from the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration's
weather prediction center shows where
people can expect rainstorms where
others can expect snow storms and where
those storms may become powerful enough
to pose risks
despite great advances in our ability to
predict natural hazards there are some
phenomena that are less predictable
which can make them harder to prepare
for you see the outer part of earth is
made up of large moving pieces called
tectonic plates these plates can grind
or slip against each other releasing
energy in the form of seismic waves
most of the time we don't even notice
these tectonic movements but especially
along boundaries or fault lines in the
plates people may experience the ground
shaking tremors of earthquakes
earthquakes can be especially dangerous
in highly populated areas where they
damage buildings roads and other forms
of human infrastructure
earthquakes are often associated with
volcanic activity since volcanoes are
also found near boundaries and fault
lines of the tectonic plates as the
plates move and magma swells up to the
surface volcanic eruptions can release
everything from clouds of gas or ash to
rivers of molten lava an earthquake in
one location may even agitate large
bodies of water enough to generate a
tsunami a huge and powerful wave along a
coastline in another tsunamis can affect
the local region as well as regions far
away
scientists can't predict an intense
earthquake volcanic eruption or tsunami
as effectively as they can a severe
weather event but they are working to
better understand earth's seismic
activity and when it poses a risk for
example they use tools like seismographs
to determine when an earthquake is
happening and its strength or magnitude
data from both minor and major tremors
may help scientists figure out the signs
that an earthquake is coming giving
communities along fault lines an early
warning to evacuate or brace themselves
rather than simply reacting to the
aftermath engineers can even use the
data they've recorded from past
earthquakes to design buildings and
other structures to withstand the
effects of future ones
communicating what they've learned may
help places that experience seismic
natural hazards to prepare far in
advance further reducing the risk that
they face
natural hazards can cause a lot of harm
but scientists are learning more every
day about why they occur and how
communities can remain resilient for my
trip i studied up on visiting a volcano
zone and was relieved to find that
there's been no signs that mount rainier
is erupting anytime soon the whole
experience really reinforced the
importance of being prepared even if
natural hazards aren't common where you
live or travel having a preparedness
plan can help you stay safe in a scary
situation these are just some examples
of how scientific research benefits
society
now if you'll excuse me i'll be setting
up an emergency kit for the next time i
lose power during a storm